hmm
[Music]
and welcome everyone to another lecture
tonight's lecture is called prepare like
a pro so we'll be going over some games
by some of the very best players in the
world and I will try to give you guys an
idea as to what goes into those games in
terms of preparation so the game I
wanted to look at is the game between
Anish giri and gukesh from this year's
tarasil chess so the difficult thing is
when you play against a player like
Anish there's a lot of things you have
to be ready for with the black pieces I
played against Anish at the Dutch
Championship over the summer you have to
be ready for D4 or sorry for E4 for D4
for C4 and also after those very first
ones there's a lot of things he can
still do so I need to open the game with
D4 and good cash respondent with the
move Knight F6 C4 and E6 this is how
most players respond to 1d4 with black
that is that in case why it goes Knight
C3 here black wants to play the NIMS are
Indian with the move Bishop B4
all right but also here again there's
many things you have to be ready for
there there's Queen C2 there's E3 F3
A3 and the list goes on and on this game
a niche does something different he
plays the move Knight F3 and here black
has some options you can go into the
Queen's inning for example with move B6
but the other main move is the move D5
and now it turns a bit more into a
Queen's Gambit decline especially after
anxious move Knight to C3 well I can
also play to move G3 and again this is
also move you have to be ready for the
Catalan opening if there's many things
black and you can always be seven Bishop
B4 we'll take the spawn over here
but most of the top players they know a
lot of these variations but on each goes
Knight T3
and here what has become very popular
recently is this move C5 the semitarage
and after C takes D5 c64 I guess also
here Anish had something prepared but
good cash played the move Bishop to B4
the rip was in defense
and here again there's a lot of things
where I can do like Queen A4 is a move
Bishop G5 you can also take on D5 first
here Bishop G5 orbish before but in this
game Anish had prepared the move Bishop
to G5
right now what black can do here is they
can take on C4 and this goes back into
the Vienna game after the move E4 so
this gets very sharp so I need to also
had to be ready for this but good cash
plays the main move which is more
consistent with the ragos and he goes H6
he's challenging this bishop on G5 and
white has to make a decision you can
move your Bishop back to H4 but now
black is a little better prepared to
take on C4 with inclusion of H6 and
Bishop to H4 I think now after E4
perhaps there might already be something
like G5 attacking the bishop and now you
take on e4 as there's no longer uh the
pin on the Knight all right so after he
checks the main move by far and large is
the trade on C6 black recaptures and
here white played E3 again they're most
like Queen A4
um and the thing is on each plate E3
castles and Rook to C1 so boys Rook C1
bringing his Rook into the game kiss
black takes he can now always recapture
as The Rook and as we see here black has
the bishop pair but the bishop won't see
it is a little bit passive White's got
some pressure on the D5 Pawn so what I
can still hope for for a small edge here
um but generally this line is not
supposed is not really known as that
dangerous but on each proofs differently
in this game
so good cash takes on C4 and each
recaptures here he plays C5 to challenge
White Center and Anish castles and he
takes on D4 and both players are still
following the main line and here there
have been a lot of draws for white plays
Knight xd4 Black Goes Bishop D7 to
prepare Knight C6 white goes Queen B3
and after 96 there's a pretty well known
repetition after it takes on C6 but I
can take here
and after Bishop C6 some games have
ended in a draw like this
all right but again Anisha different had
different intentions in this game so we
played the move 94 attacking the queen
and F6 the queen moved back to E7
still the main move
and Anish played A3 he's attacking this
bishop but again like if you want to go
into into a variation like this you also
perhaps have to look almost like Queen
G6 and add a lot of deviations uh
earlier so Queen E7 was played now A3 by
Anisha taking the bishop
the bishop moves back to A5
white X here on D4 and Blackwell is rook
d8 and again up until this point all of
this has been known yet and black is
supposed to be doing pretty well here
they have the two Bishops they also have
the slightly better Pawn structure
because this D4 Pawn is isolated so you
might be wondering like why would white
even want to go for this position right
well the one thing white has got going
for them is that they have a lead in
development like why it's got two
knights developed a bishop as well The
Rook is into the game whereas black has
one Bishop active this bishop is not
active yet and neither is the Knight
and here Anish
I don't know if it was a novelty but it
was certainly not a move that had been
played before the top level
you played the move Rook C2
you might be wondering okay why what is
so special about this move and when
Anisha talks about this move in an
interview he said that when he looked at
this position with the computer it shows
the move Rook C2
and it evaluates this move as 0.02
why does he want to go for this move and
here black still has a lot of options
that are fine for them
they can actually go Bishop D7 and 97
those two moves are a pretty fine for
black but the thing is even though there
are multiple moves that are fine now
black is gonna walk a tight robe later
and we'll soon enough see why
I actually could have played the move
Knight E7
and here
um white it does allow by the play to
move D5
and here black has two moves black can
go either Knight of six or take on D5
but again like if you're playing against
if you're playing against one of the
best players in the world and they're
blitzing out every move it's not that
easy to go for something like this
like let's say you're going out of six
now I can go D6 attack the queen
and here already
um black only has one move which is okay
for them does anyone have any areas what
what should black play in this position
to to hang on
the Queen's under attack we see that
taking here doesn't work as wide gets
another queen so the queen has to move
so where's the wrong thing the queen
looks like the best score for the queen
D7
well D7 is possible but I think here
white gets to move 95 with a tempo
so
the queen actually should go to f8
but then you allow this and the king is
a little bit exposed and again if you're
playing in someone who's playing Super
quickly you you feel a little bit
nervous going into stuff like this and
white can play with like 24 attacking
this
and then here I think now you have to
play Queen G7 to hold the balance
so just goes to show how how difficult
it is because
what some people don't understand who uh
well especially people who do not play
chess a robot especially but
even those who do play Chess at the top
level
they sometimes prepare for weeks or days
for a single game
like Tata steals a tournament that's
happening every year and Anish usually
has a training camp where he looks for
the strainers at different openings he's
looking for new ideas and novelties that
he can try against his opponents and
what you have to do is at every movie
you're going to have to analyze a lot of
moves
so let's say here after move Rook C2 he
has to look at Bishop D7 here so look at
97 uh moves like Bishop D6
maybe also moves like Asics have to be
looked at he said that the foul goes on
and on and on like at every move he
might be checking 10 moves so that he
knows what to do like let's say 96 is
also a very reasonable what should he do
there
right
um but good cash played a move which is
pretty typical for this variation of one
that looks pretty solid he played the
move Bishop to D7
all right so with the move Bishop D7 he
wants to go Bishop C6 put some pressure
on this Knight on e4 and then later this
Knight can still develop here looks
pretty harmonious for black right
but how how does white proceed here
what was the point behind this move Rook
C2 how does Anish want to place his
pieces
how do we continue to improve our
position here
all right so uh so you want to double
them on the C4 where do you want to
double the queen of Rook
right we can also well we can
we can double them on the default but
let's say going here
but like Rook D2
um we don't need to play Rook C2 for
that right I mean then we could have
also played let's say
queen queen E3 here followed by Rook
here
right so what was the idea behind the
move Rook C2
I have to look for a good setup for
pieces
because again right now white setup
looks quite innocuous
but we'll see the potential behind the
White's position very soon
so how do we how do we place our pieces
here
where's this Rook had it now now we've
played Rook C2
exactly yep that is Rook to E2 excellent
very good we put the rook in E2 to Ida's
Queen on E7
and now the radius of of D5 and by the
way one variation that I also wanted to
show like 97 by the way was fine
um
wait sorry it has to Rook C2 Knight D7
was a fine move and after D5 so Knight
F6 was fine but it feels a little bit
risky to let why take here and open up
the king side black can also take here
but then after Queen xd5 you have to
spawn Knight B6 attacking the queen
well I can take here black can take here
and there's Bishop B3
and
um here it may look like white still has
a slight Edge because this bishop is
active on this diagonal there's Bishop
P6
y goes rookie one attacking the queen
and here black has only one move that
fully maintains the quality
which is the move Rook D1
with the idea that in case you take now
black ticks here and wins back the
exchange so it's not that easy to go for
this variation or you have to see all of
this when you play 97 and you have to
see that you have that move rookie on at
the end so again that's the the pressure
that these top players are trying to put
on their opponents but anyway let's
continue with the game so make sure this
sound was played rookie two and black
played Bishop C6
Black's putting pressure on this line
and E4 and now they want to develop with
Knight to D7
so how does white continue here how does
white continue to place their pieces
we've got the Rook on a good Square
so how do we continue from here
does anyone have any ideas
so we've got this Rook on a good square
right it's on the e-file it's eyeing the
screen potentially over here
oh
so some people in the chat have found
some
some good plants
so what we can play here is the move
Queen to C2
playing with Queen C2 and specifically
to also get out of this D file
right because in some positions we might
want to go for that D5 push again
um
but like let's say we let's say we play
somewhere like D4 Bishop B6 America if
you want right I think here black can
just play something like 97 and in case
of D5 black can play net of six and take
advantage of this pin along the D file
so we want to we want to get out of the
pin on the D file but also with this
move we we kind of eye the black king a
little bit like we have these Knights
over here it's kind of looking in this
direction and we'll see that that'll
that will play a role later
now here black would love to just
develop with him of 97 and in case black
also can go Knight F6 it feels like
Black's doing pretty fine
because after Knight F6
um black you know brings a knight over
is putting pressure again black is the
bishop bear but 90 97 is not a good move
it runs into a pretty strong response
from wide so does anyone have any idea
what I can do here
okay
mm-hmm
any ideas how come I use their
their active peace Army here
exactly here y goes D5
takes the bishop
any case black takes the palm
what does y do here
well I mean if we take and go Knight C3
the best we can hope for is that we get
the piece back right and black and just
move the bishop out of the way
again
keep in mind what I was saying earlier
right that
would move Queen C2 were indirectly
eyeing the King on G8
so how do we take advantage of that here
don't be too tunnel then on what's
happening in the center
it's actually all about the king over
here
how can you get that how can you get to
that King
also keep in mind that you have this
discovery
on the e-file
so we're exactly so you go Knight G5
you take the queen and now this is a
threat and black is lost they're gonna
have to give up their Queen somehow with
some for like takes but black just
doesn't get enough here they have two
minor pieces which is not enough for the
queen
and as Anish said in one of his
interviews
that like if you're playing with black
and you see that the natural move like
97 does not work because of D5 it's
already a little bit unpleasant like you
see how you can lose the game it's
already a small psychological blow
now what black should do here is a
little bit of natural black should play
to move Rook C8 move the Rook again and
line it up with the queen
and after Queen E3 here black can
actually take an E4 and after Rock takes
go Knight D7
um because now D5 runs into Knight C5
so that is how black should apply but
bukukash plays the move Bishop to B6
all right so he's putting some pressure
on the spawn over here
all right so how do we continue here
so we see that most of our pieces are
active right I mean our Rook is active
this Rook over here both nights are
active or Bishop as well or queen
but
how can we further improve the position
here
indeed a white played the move Rook fe1
exactly he brought this Rook into the
game as well
all right and here good cash already
made the losing mistake of the game
he played them with King h8 which looks
pretty it doesn't look terrible
and we'll soon see why he played that
move
let's say black goes for a move like
Bishop takes D4
here what has a has a very strong
combination can does anyone in the chat
or an audience have any idea what black
can do here or what white can do here
and this combination here is the the
main theme of the game we'll see this
occur
a lot of times
foreign
is to move Knight eg5 anyway
threatening made
and in case black takes then there's no
rocktek C6
and after it takes you take the Queen's
under attack
this diagonal is getting ripped open
and there's no good way for black here
to survive the attack
why it's doing very well you for example
if you take and after king of fade for
the moment black has enough has a lot of
pieces because they have two Rooks and a
bishop of Y can take here and after
takes there's Queen C5 and you pick up
the Rook
so that is really the
uh we will see this theme occur a lot
over here
all right and in case
I think after
Queen F7 then there's Knight takes G5
you take the queen
there's this threat and also here I
believe black doesn't um survive the
attack
all right so Bishop takes D4 is is now
possible and perhaps maybe that's
something go cash underestimated maybe
he thought after Bishop B6 Anish would
have to go here
so Rook if you want us played for white
and now here so here's the thing like in
this game we've been going over
questions like okay how does white win
here and those are all the fun questions
but now I imagine you're playing with
the black pieces you're playing against
a niche you're super well prepared he's
blitzing out every move
here black only has one move to stay in
the game
like only as one move all the other
moves are actually quite bad
um
what should black play here to to hang
on
does anyone have any ideas and I'll give
you guys a hint
we'll see to this sacrifice with Knight
G5 takes on Rook takes E6 happens a lot
so black is one move
to make sure that that sacrifice does
not happen
what should black do here
right Bishop takes Knight as a move but
I think here white takes with the
I think with the Rook
thing with the Rook
and this position is also not very good
for black because um
D5 now is a big threat also this is a
threat
so
any other ideas
okay Bishop C4 it stops it stops this
move
but black has a move to make black as a
move they make sure that y does not have
this combination with
95 and Rook take C6
so the Casual player in case black was
97 then there's this move D5
sacrificing the pollen in case you take
there's Knight eg5
I think the queen of threatening
checkmate
so that's a little bit unpleasant for
black there's no easy way to get the
knight in
Evan is kind of
added Bishop D7 has been suggested it
strengthens the E6 point but it does so
in a very
uh passive way so actually someone in a
chat has found the move
there's only one way for black to uh
to keep an acceptable position here
which is with the move Bishop to D5
blocking the diagonal this way that
being said that this position also isn't
a whole lot of fun well I can take on D5
again you cannot take this opponents
there's Knight e25
and wide wins
so you have to take with the rook and
here where I can get a pretty
Pleasant Advantage after Knight C3
Rook D6
what does y do here
how does white get the
advantage
all right
because again if Blake gets the time to
get their pieces into the game they're
doing pretty all right because they have
the slightly better Pawn structure
but here white has a way to actually get
the better Pawn structure
so the move here for white is the move
D5
taking upon E6
black can bring their Knight into the
game but after takes after some trades
we see that wide is a bit better because
now black has this isolated Pawn over
here why no longer has any weaknesses
but you know why it's better but it's
not the end of the world
right
the good cash played the move King to h8
he was hoping that with this move he
would step out of the danger a little
bit but
that's not quite the case
here oh here oh Anish came up with uh
with a really good move with a quite a
hammer blow
what is why I play in this position
and I believe Anish said later that this
move might have still been in his foul
but the foul was just so big that he he
didn't remember but he found the move
over to board
H4 is a move but there's something again
like we're looking for a hammer blow
here H4 might improve the position but
not too dramatically or anything
um
and again keep in mind that if you give
black the time to consolidate black
isn't doing too bad
but again White's got a crushing move
here
so the move to the right place and it
has been found by some people in the
chat is the move Knight eg5 anyway
black takes and what does y do now
what does the idb behind giving up the
Knight
and black by the way has to take because
white is turning made
so black takes a no
um
so any areas
some people have have found it in the
chat
um so what y does here is indeed the
move Rook takes E6
sacking The Rook
black has to take
an idea really is to push the queen away
so the Y can take this Pawn over here if
y takes here while it's running mate
again
okay so black takes wider captures so
the queen is under attack
now let's say the queen moves right
let's say the queen moves here what do
we do now
exactly yep which is take this Pawn over
here why it's turning made and there's
no good way for black to defend like
there's Queen G8 but I think here
there's probably multiple ways to win I
mean I assume something like
let's say queen F5 and I don't think
there's a good way to stop made over
here
so blacks down likes up a lot of
material but they're just getting
checkmated so
um
black decided to give up their Queen by
taking
on
E6 but another pretty variation
so let's say black goes Queen F7 we can
win the queen but this is even better
take here we attack the queen of thread
and made
let's say black goes Queen H5 here what
is what is white play in this position
here why it's got a pretty move
all right
okay so one person has found it but
others are still struggling a little bit
um because Bishop B2 I can just take the
Knight the knight's a very important
attacker
in case of rookie ape like and probably
just take
but in this position right here why does
the move Rook H6 check
and that is that in case black takes the
pawn now there's made over here
in case you take the queen now there's
check
you lose your queen with a check because
the King goes here now there's check
and it's gonna be made and well if you
go King back then I can check over here
at the very least I can pick up the Roku
check and the attack doesn't stop
anytime soon actually night I mean why
it's winning here one way or another
all right so there's there's no good way
for black to to hang on to um to the
queen so black just gave him the queen
for The Rook right recaptured and now
black took on um on F3 now why can we
capture and well it's probably still
winning
but I think the move that Anish played
is even better
does anyone have because again we can we
can still go after the black king on ha
which is almost check made it yes this
bishop is blocking is staying away this
Square
so a check along the HL will be deadly
so how can we continue here with white
well
um which one creates one of only one of
those two moves creates a very
direct threat
let me ask you
um does Queen of
wealth threat does Queen of five create
if y gets another move here let's say
black does this what does y do here
exactly Queen H3 and that's made
so then the question is like yeah so
queen of five looks like a good move
does does Queen G6 create a threat
right it doesn't because the H5
yeah all right no worries yeah so this
does not create a threat so I don't I
don't like it as much I mean maybe here
this move might still be winning I don't
know but you also have to keep in mind
that after most like Queen G6
black might be able to play a move like
um
let's say
something like maybe black can even go
here
you know to keep covering the square
although
yeah and it's not it's not as clear-cut
I mean one variation I was thinking
about is let's say F3
maybe black can take here with a check
the King was over maybe someone like
Bishop D3 so they can block like you
never have to underestimate uh that
often black still has a lot of defensive
resources you know and then also dealing
with Checkmate threads over here and
here this might actually already be it
might already be gone and again keep in
mind black is a lot of material for the
queen so you have to be very very
careful
so I need to play The Right Move he
played Queen F5 threatening Checkmate
over here
all right now let's say black goes
Bishop H5
to cover the Checkmate thread what does
y do here
all right well
um
see Jared Jared you mean I guess you
don't mean Rook D6 here right because
Queen H3 is still checkmate
but what else do I do here is the bishop
to H5
indeed the move is Rock takes G5 you
take the bishop we're now threatening
The Rook as it's defended but black
assembly hasn't has no good way to deal
with the attacking bishop and it's also
going to be it's just going to be made
um because in case you
you move anywhere then there's Queen H4
Checkmate and because G6 there's always
Checkmate over here
so
switch 5 does not work
so therefore
good cash played the move Bishop to E4
all right now what should white play
here
for first question first what is the ID
behind wish before let's say why it goes
Queen H3 here
exactly another block of the bishop yep
and
you have Bishop 5
but here first of all the king can run
but also black and gold G6
error D7 and
again it's very unclear because again
Black's got a lot of pieces for the
queen
so what do we do here
because we have to take it exactly we
just take the bishop
all right so here
I'm trying to think
good cash
I like he also could have gone rookie
eight here
um
I'm trying to think
what the problem was
with
yeah so let's say black goes Rook to
E-8 what does
what does y do here
Queen B7 is a is a pretty
um
is a pretty reasonable move
now
um
in case black takes here this actually
loses for black because we check over
here
we take the Rook
and we're going to win more material
because let's say black goes 96
what else do I do here
exactly then Queenie four track perfect
and we pick up the Rook but the drawback
of Queen xb7 is that here black has the
opportunity to play a move like
Knight A6
and you know we can take the knife but
then you take our Bishop
so
after rookie 8
we have to look for something else
we have to say focused on the black king
so what does y do here
and also to answer some questions in the
chat like you can let's say go you can
go from like Queen F7 to throw in
Checkmate again
and I would still prefer white white
here
but keep in mind the black is a lot of
pieces black is a rook a knight and
Bishop now generally Rooks are are
considered to be worth five points and
minor pieces are are considered to be
worth three
so black has got five
eight eleven pieces 11 points and
equities are considered to be worth nine
right so
I would still prefer white because black
skin is pretty weak and White's got more
pawns but it's not going to be easy to
win this one at all
but
let's stay focused on the black king why
it actually
can
white actually can add an attacker here
try it seems surprising
right because we only have a queen and a
bishop
there's a way here for Y2 add an extra
piece in into the attack
Pony five is a move but here black can
again play something like
I think here black maybe plays something
like 97. and then now the Knight joint
joins the defense
thank you
so some people in the chat have found
the right idea
I'll give you another hint I'll give you
another hint we see that very often on
why it's back rank is weak right some of
the variations
so this move also deals with that
before so indeed H4 is a very nice move
of course black cannot take this is this
is Checkmate right away
and if black does something else it's
going to be quite useful that we take
here and this this phone will actually
helping the attack like let's say black
goes here
we take again we threaten mate
um let's say black goes here I mean
taking is good but there's even
Checkmate over here
and in case black takes we now recapture
and we always have the idea to give a
check over here and then go G6
and even though might not be Checkmate
right away even though it still looks
very scary for black
there are always ideas to just pick up
this Pawn over here
which will witness the game like let's
say black goes here I think just check
G7 should win
so it's four very good black has to play
G4 here I believe
um and I think here we just take
and then we get to this position which
is pretty good for why the may be
holdable for black or it objectively
it's probably winning for right but this
gives like the best chances to hold the
black played the move Rook takes D4
tagging the queen and threatening
Checkmate um surrounding Checkmate over
here
all right so what does y do now
yeah good question sidearms I mean that
was better but
um White's still better there but that
was Black's best chance to hold on
so what is why I play here our Queen is
under attack and black turns background
checkmate
so ideally we want to deal with that but
we also want to make a move that creates
threats for us again right
22 as possible
because we send Checkmate over here but
here black might be able to play G6
and we've got check but there's King H7
and Black's still in the game so you've
got the right idea but not trying to
find a move that's
a little bit better
so similar idea just a little bit more
precise
exactly so we go queen of three very
good so we'll go Queen F3 we threaten
Checkmate over here and now we also have
videos of checks here so blackplay G4
all right and now
where do we go with our Queen
we go queen of a check King H7
all right and how do we continue the
attack
uh you mean F5 or sorry yeah Bishop five
exactly yeah check
all right now here maybe black should
have played the move
ah G6 although there's also wait there's
check
this feels very bad for black but I
don't see the wind right away in case of
check there's here
this should win somehow for white
just trying to think exactly how
but this should win one way or another
um
anyway
um in this position black played the
move King to H6 the king moved up
so what does
what does white play here
for King H6
oh well let's have a Queenie trade and
black ghost King here
I'm about it just to point real quick
and some people have pointed out in the
chat indeed after uh in this variation y
goes Bishop C2 and there's no good way
for black to deal with uh with this
threat
um just to show a couple variations like
let's say you go Rook D6 to defend upon
and there's queen of Fate you pick up
the Rook okay so let's say 97
you can take here check and then you
have this check over here
and yeah so there's just no good way for
black to defend in case of
here I think now we play let's say check
take check and pick up the rook and wide
wins again
all right so King H6 was played
okay so now keep in mind
again black is still threatening
Checkmate Checkmate over here
and the problem is in case we checked
then the king steps up
and the King kind of escapes right
so well good players often try to do is
they try to find moves they try to find
multi-purpose moves
so you want to look for a move
that oh uh let me let me not point out
you want to find a move that stops Rook
D1
and you also want to find a move that
makes sure
uh that the king does not run out
because the king you want to check with
the King over here right it's really
stuck
oh Bishop takes Chief four has been
suggested but black just takes
H4 is a move it's been suggested in the
chat but I guess black just takes
Bishop C2 grade move Bishop C2 you stop
rookie when checkmate
and here black actually resigned
because uh White now is threatening well
let's say black doesn't do anything like
white standing check
s and uh it's going to be made like the
king doesn't doesn't escape like you're
just check and made
there's nothing that the black can do
because in case of let's say a rook Rook
here then I think you
check over here and again the king is
getting checkmated computers G3 after G5
there's Checkmate over here
so
yeah uh pretty pretty smooth win for for
our niche in this game and quite a tough
loss for gukesh as we saw in this game
he never really got into the game and
each was in his preparation
uh he was still blitzing
up until
this point for sure and he he even had
this stuff with 90 G5 in his file you
only had to calculate this and he won
the game so that's sometimes how it goes
um so you might be saying like well you
know he didn't have to find a single
move on his own but of course there's a
lot of work and preparation that goes
into this and yeah that's um that that's
what makes chess sometimes search um
such a tough game but I hope all of you
all of you guys enjoyed this lecture
both in person and on Twitch and YouTube
um again thanks wrong for watching and I
hope to to see all of you guys for the
next lectures that are coming up
[Music]